even the worst neighborhood in America  in the world but here they can rally  behind we can't put a machine on the  street machine they want by Michael  Keaton the conscience something that  knows it feels like baby Spencer yet  we're gonna put a man inside a machine  has asked us to control [ __ ]  so much pretty [ __ ] awesome it's  coming oh wow I just look so cool don't  play good-cop bad-cop Robocop yeah  thank you for your cooperation  that's how you make a Robocop damn dude  that film looks like district 9 meets  the original Robocop and they made a  darker that's always the best way to go  I hope it's as like bloody and [ __ ] I  don't know a rating this movie is but  damn that movie looks [ __ ] awesome it  makes you want to just kick some ass it  looks like a damn good science-fiction  action adventure flick